الغاره وقعت على بعد امطار قليله فقط من
المتحف ولم تتمكن نوافد المبنى الذي يعود
تاريخه الى نهايه القرن ال من تحمل قوه
الانفجار بعيد ذلك بثت السلطات المحليه
صور الاضرار التي اظهرت اللوحات التي كانت
معروضه وهي ملقات على الارض كما يبدو
بوضوح تصدع
الجدران تعرضت النوافذ واللوحات لاضرار
كبيره وكذلك كسقف وجدران المتحف في الوقت
الحالي التحقيقات جاريه لتحديد الاضرار
التي لا يمكننا رؤيتها
الان خلال ليله الاحد الى الاثنين اصابت
الصواريخ الروسيه وغارات الطائرات بدون
طيار ثمانيه اشخاص في اوديسا هذه المدينه
الساحليه الواقعه في جنوب اوكرانيا والحقت
اضرارا ايضا بالمباني السكنيه وهذه ليست
المره الاولى التي يتعرض فيها المركز
التاريخي للمدينه لاضر منذ بدء الصراع مما
ادى الى ادراجه على قائمه التراث المهدد
بالخطر من قبل منظمه اليونسكو في يناير
الماضي وفيما شهد يوم الاثنين هجمات مضاده
روسيه على الجبهتين الجنوبيه والشرقيه
اعلنت كيف انها دمرت سفينه روسيه كبيره في
حوض بناء سفن بيرش في شرق شبه جزيره
القرمه التي تحتلها
موسو اشكر كل من ساهم في تدمير السفينه
الروسيه حظ لبناء السفن في كيرتش انه
استهداف مهم لاحد مصادر الارهاب الروسي ضد
اوكرانيا منذ بدء هجومها المضاد هذا الصيف
كثفت كياف هجماتها ضد الاسطول الروسي في
شبه جزيره القرم التي ضمتها موسكو في عام
2014 والتي تعد بمثابه قاعدتها الخلفيه في
الصراع